now it's time for a check-in with the
drew van that's been making its way
across the country
here's noah and karen pulling up on a
special drew gooder mission
in nashville tennessee and we will see
them in a few minutes but first
let's go to fox 17 news reporter justin
mcfarlane along with christy holman
who works at hermitage elementary school
in nashville hi guys
i know i know christy you've made it
your mission to help those in
underserved communities you've been
setting up
fundraisers organizing food drives and
even
buying clothes for students and families
in need
that's amazing yeah thank you yes
we just wanted to know like where your
drive comes from
to help people and why this is personal
for you
i um i was a foster child so
that just i was in about seven or eight
different foster homes before i was
adopted by the age of seven
and you know it's just i know what it
feels like to just not know where your
next meal is coming from
when you don't have any comfort you know
you don't know where you're going to be
the next day
all your clothes are in a bag and you
know it just
all that comes from just experience for
me
that is absolutely incredible can you
tell me about your latest project
how are you able to help out in this
last go around that we've had
well i found out that a janitor at our
school that used to work here
she had become homeless after the last
flood and she had two special needs
children
and she was living in her car
and i knew what that feeling is like to
not you know know that you don't have a
home
so i just started a gofundme for her
and she collected over ten thousand
dollars
and she's actually in an apartment right
now with her family
together we just wanted to do something
special for you and noah and karen who
have been driving the dream van across
the country
have a little something for you right
over here come on don't be shy step on
over step on over
thank you so much oh my gosh thank you
all so
much oh my gosh that's awesome thank you
drew
i just want to say thank you to chrissy
holman
justin mcfarland and our friends over at
fox 17 news
and noah and karen we love you
and we'll see you at the next stop we're
so excited to be doing this with you and
thank you to our viewers and vff's
for watching today and hopefully we're
lucky enough to maybe see you tomorrow
sounds good